now Henry Mike remembers that day and do
you want to tell the story about how you
remember how he arrived and to travel
and everything well
Henry as I remember it you you we sent
for you and you didn't live very close
to the airport and so you had to get up
very very early in the morning and
travel I guess it was to Dallas that's
right yeah excuse me
Thanks yeah I I had to I had to do some
crazy you know there was no direct
flight from where I lived so I had to
drive very far to an airport that would
bring me there on time and of course I
didn't have an agent or anything at this
point I've just done a couple of
projects and I was going out to LA for
the first time in my life and Universal
was also piggybacking the the ADR the
looping that I had to do for the first
film raggedy men that I had done for
Jack this they were putting it all
together and I knew that I had an
audition with Steven Spielberg did you
know who Steven was I knew Raiders of
the Lost Ark right because I had seen
that and because he had done jaws Raider
jaws Raiders Close Encounters it was
actually he was on the set he was
filming poltergeist at the time that I
read for him I I had met with with
Steven the the day before on the set of
poltergeist and he said tomorrow we're
gonna do a reading and I thought okay
dude there was no script you know no one
could see the script because it was very
secret so I thought all right no go in
how old were you I was nine nine and I
had a bullwhip
for Raiders because I was a big Harrison
Ford family and I thought well I
probably won't get the part but I'll get
to talk to Steven Spielberg about
Raiders of the Lost Ark and then I went
in and I I think I read a page of some
you know the scene from some other film
and I thought oh this is awful I've
really blown it at nine you thought this
yeah well you know because you don't
really know like I I didn't really
understand the whole process I just knew
that this was expected of me
you know I was supposed to deliver and I
remember reading this scene and thinking
oh I'm really bad at reading this off a
page and I think Mike kind of sensed
that and they obviously wanted to see if
I could go you know find a throttle
somewhere and then this happened and
it's never happened again that someone
actually said oh you got the job and the
room I've always been waiting for it
that's right it doesn't happen like that
whole scene was ad-libbed yeah I mean we
both just ad-libbed that scene it's
there was nothing on paper
so don't Steven just say I want you to
get this emotion out of him I want you
to push him to the point where he gets
upset or was that just that just came
well it came but see what had happened
was Henry was so tired that that the the
readings he had done with me he was just
kind of and so when I told Stephen and
Stephen looked at some of the stuff on
the tape he said okay this is what you
have to do and he told me to do that and
Henry just followed and went along with
it and that seemed that we have just run
was totally ad-libbed and he was nine
years old I mean how brilliant
I was flying on instinct
did you understand when he said you've
got the job
did you know or did you just go I mean I
did you see I smile yeah but I was kind
of smiling like are they are they joking
with me or that's this I it had never
occurred to me actually like how the
business worked I didn't think about
that at all I didn't think that the
decision went beyond those people in the
room or that there were other people
involved really I mean I had been on a
set before I had done two things before
this and in fact my my lucky streak was
was broken I went in to audition for you
for the toy and and I didn't get it and
that was the that was my fourth audition
and that was the first one that I lost
so you you you set my mind straight for
the rest of my career